I'm doing this videos give us an
overview of the first significant
dynasties in ancient and Imperial China
now in a previous video we talked about
the Shia dynasty which were not sure
whether it exists because we don't have
a lot of historical documentation but
based on legend it apparently emerged
around 2100 2200 BCE so we're talking
about over 4000 years ago and lasted
until the emergence of the Shang Dynasty
in 1600 BCE
now the Shang Dynasty you could view the
first real historical dynasty because we
have artifacts we have archaeological
evidence we even have writing the famous
oracle bones of the shang dynasty that
were used to make decisions to
prognosticate about the future and
what's interesting about this writing on
these oracle bones that are over 3,000
years old is that modern Chinese script
has actually evolved from this over
3,000 year old writing also in that
Shang Dynasty we see major bronze
artifacts and it's once again it's the
first real historical evidence we see of
a of a reasonably large geographic area
being unified around the yellow and the
Yangtze River now in that video on the
shang dynasty we talk about how it
eventually falls in 1046 BCE and it
falls to the jo dynasty and the jo
dynasty they defeat the last Shang
Emperor dicen at the Battle of mu Yi in
1046 and based on their view of things
or current historical accounts Deason
became a corrupt ruler he was under the
influence of his consort and the Jo's
say hey the reason why we were able to
defeat them and overthrow them and
establish a new dynasty it's because of
the Mandate of Heaven the Mandate of
Heaven is this idea that will be
incorporated by the Jo dynasty and then
becomes part of Chinese culture and
tradition for thousands of years after
that heaven in this sense is not a place
in the clouds
some might imagine in a Western
tradition it's really you could view it
as a guiding force of the universe and
it's this idea that if leaders become
incapable they become correct that this
guiding force of the universe will throw
them out and put more capable leaders in
power and so King Lou of Jo who defeats
D sin at the Battle of mu yi he invokes
this Mandate of Heaven and will continue
to be invoked throughout the Jo dynasty
now the Jo dynasty is going to be a very
long lasting dynasty but it is not
centralized it can be described as kind
of a feudal system there's multiple
kingdoms who have allegiance to the Jo's
and at multiple times they have
different degrees of autonomy enough
power now the Jo dynasty is generally
divided into the Western Jo when the
Capitals in the West and the eastern Jo
dynasty when the capital moves to the
east now the eastern Jo dynasty this
period right over here between 770 BCE
and 476 BCE often known as the spring
and autumn period this is often referred
to as a significant period of a
philosophical a philosophical Golden Age
in China it was the time of Confucius it
was the time of Lao Tzu who comes up
with the Tao or the core of the bowel
philosophy so a lot of major
philosophical underpinnings of even
modern China start to emerge in this
time now at the latter half of the
eastern jo period you have the warring
States Period and that's where you see
these dotted lines and the Jo dynasty
which was already very decentralized
becomes even more fragmented and China
really doesn't get well unified again
until 221 BCE in 221 BCE you have the
emergence of the Qin Dynasty and even
though the Qin Dynasty is very
short-lived it only lasts a few decades
it's significant and that it's the first
really strong central dynasty it's often
referred to as the first imperial
dynasty as we mentioned about the Jo's
very distant decentralized this feudal
system but the Qin Dynasty under chin
she long D or sometimes chin she long he
is a very strong ruler he sets up this
legalistic government is very strict
legal code
he really oppressed his opponents in
significant ways but the byproduct of
that is he was able to really unify
China now other things that he did the
Great Wall of China which didn't just
get built by him but there were already
walls that were that were being erected
throughout China at this time he started
to unify these walls and then break down
the walls that were within his empire
and so he's often created is really
starting the formation of the what we
now call the Great Wall of China which
was kept being built and and improved
upon by later generations later
dynasties the other thing that he is
well known for is establishing this
centralized bureaucracy that has that
where the civil servants are able to
earn their spots based on taking exams
this would last for several thousand
years in China now as I mentioned the
Qin Dynasty would be short-lived but
then it would be followed by one of the
most significant dynasties in Chinese
history that really takes the work of
the Qin but makes it a little bit more
moderate and the Han Dynasty is is often
referred to by Chinese historians as the
Golden Age of China it's a time where
Confucian philosophy really becomes
dominant you have significant advances
in math science and technology this is
an image of the nine chapters on the
mathematical art where ideas like
Gaussian elimination and Kramer's rule
things that wouldn't be explored in
Europe for over a thousand years are
documented during Han China you have the
famous papermaking
emerge during Han China and as you can
see it lasts for over 400 years there's
a brief period right over here where you
have the where you have the syn dynasty
gets established but and that separates
the Western Han from the eastern Han but
this is a significant period of
development of Chinese philosophy
Chinese writing Chinese technology that
lasts even until today and to get an
appreciation of the Confucius Confucian
philosophy remember Confucian lived over
several hundred years
before the Han Dynasty but this is when
it really becomes the philosophy or even
you could think of the religion of China
I'll leave you with a few quote from
Confucius and I'll do a whole video on
him later on but these are some of my
favorite real knowledge is to know the
extent of one's ignorant and this is a
version of the Golden Rule do not impose
on others what you yourself do not
desire and to put into context these
ideas of Confucius the writing the the
mathematics that was developed there it
was the civil service these continued on
for several thousand years and this was
during the time interesting about what
else was going on the world this was at
the time of the Roman Empire and so it
is interesting that at the time of the
chin and then Han dynasties where you
first have this real centralized Empire
that was right around the time that Rome
itself was also becoming centralized and
it's interesting to think about what was
it about that period of history where
you have these two significant empires
starting to really emerge and they
weren't completely isolated there was
actually interaction between the two